[Music]
you know how they play
[Applause]
I want to do my normal YouTube uh intro
but I I really can't because it's ladies
and gentlemen of YouTube boogie2988
coming at you live once again through
the power of the internet yeah oh yeah
Jordan that's amazing dude come on
okay so this is one of the podcasts that
I've done this is just put purely for me
[__] who watches I don't care any but
anything because I've wanted to meet you
and hang out with you for about 10 years
yeah I I think it's been that long since
you and I first connected and you once
said to me if you're ever in London and
I'm like when the hell is that gonna
happen yeah are you when you're in
Arkansas you're like when the hell is
that uh here we are it's been a wild
strange trip hasn't it it's it's been
wonderful watching you grow and do
everything you've done like when I first
started watching you you didn't even
have a million subscribers I remember
when you hit a million in my mind as a
fan being blown being like wow this guy
really did it the True Underdog of the
internet this guy has done it all he got
this is when you were doing deals with
like PlayStation yeah yeah everything
was blowing up for you and you just
exploded on the internet everyone was
watching you was amazing right place
right time I mean I always say that
um you know how to get really lucky like
Lightning's run strikes right but you
also have to put yourself in a
thunderstorm if you want lightning to
hit and I just put myself in the right
thunderstorm you know you you know what
it is with you the I think I talk as a
as a watcher into on my own journey is
uh authenticity you are you and no one
else can be you better than you con I
have strayed away from that in like 2018
2019 which was one of my biggest
mistakes I think when I was First on
YouTube was truly authentically me and
then uh keemstar even advised me like a
2017 where the internet started like
turning against me a little bit he's
like be the bad guy play the heel and
I've always been like an Andy Kaufman
fan I'm wearing I think my Andy Kaufman
hurt today and I thought well I could
play the bad guy right so I tried I like
put myself out there and did all the
negative things and it was not authentic
and um some it was authentic I was going
through some [__] but I feel that though
she has what happened and Logan Paul
went through it I feel like it the the
the devil on the shoulder sometimes says
to you like if everyone's laying into
you then go with it and and take that
negative energy and adopt it yeah and
throw it right back at them yeah but
that in a way I feel like they win when
you do that but they do and that's why
I've been through my [__] as well as you
have and I've tried not to do that
because in my head I'm like oh I'm just
validating your [__] theories about
me these people who don't know me who've
got all this weird [__] going on in
their own lives they're putting that on
you 100 yeah they want you to be this
horrible person that you're not right
but when you lean into that and because
your negativity Spurs you on it it [__]
you over well I started the podcast uh
called power of the internet I've got uh
an interview with keemstar up on that
channel I also like three episodes long
at this point but in that interview with
keemstar he pointed out
um like yeah I'm a piece of [__] and I
do some shitty things right but the
problem is they're not satisfied with
that they need me to be so much more and
so much worse than I actually am and
they take something and they invent it
and they twist it and whatever and he
has advised me a million times but
everyone has advised me that if you ever
even
let's take that I was abusive to my wife
as an example
um my ex-wife did me the favor of coming
out on like public channels she doesn't
like to be a public person but she came
on a public channel so like saying these
rumors are false it's absurd that you
guys think that but because she
validated that now people are saying oh
see she's talking about it it must be
true I bet he paid her to do it I bet he
coerced her what if he threatened her
life right and so like the best thing
the one thing I've learned on the
Internet is you do not those people have
to be
we have to have an invisible wall
between you and you can't look at his
area acknowledgment and the minute you
even acknowledge that this is even a
thing you're losing don't explain
yourself you're just being here bro
friends and that's what who we fell in
love with as a as a character obviously
there was Francis and then there's
Boogie a man behind that is the true
real you yeah who isn't the Entertainer
who's just the guy sitting in his house
right right there is a difference
between all three of those people but
for me I always just wanted to know what
you thought about life about uh gaming
about the news about current events well
I can tell you everything that you want
to know today I will tell you my I have
I have been you've heard me say in my
journey a million times that when I get
my mental health right that's on my
physical health will follow but I have
to get my mental health right I know
that because every therapist I ever
spoke to told me that right like hey I
want to lose weight okay well you got to
fix your brain we're gonna fix your
heart we're gonna fix your brain okay
but I don't want to lose weight first
well that's not how this works and if
you lost it you're going to get him back
anyway because you're an addict and
you're dealing with pain let's solve the
pain let's solve the problems and so I
have spent since my bypass surgery that
entire time in very intense therapy
especially during covet and in the last
year I introduced psychedelic therapy to
it and I have vastly changed my
perception of the world perception of my
own body and perception of my own mind
and it is I think that's why I'm having
a fight in London that's why I'm here uh
it's so funny because three months ago
during my first session with my shaman
um we took five grams of uh penis envy
mushrooms by Charlotte hands me the the
mushrooms it's like now are you ready
for everything to change and I'm like
sure I don't know what the [__] I'm
agreeing to just feed me candy I'm an
idiot you know
um and now three months later I'm in
London fighting a guy so he wasn't wrong
no everything I've seen a video from you
yeah you were talking about why you're
doing this and your whole attitude
demeanor I think addicts do often need
to substitute uh unhealthy addiction for
a healthier 100 I think that's the best
way out I was watching the way you were
speaking and I was like ah yeah the
tiger I couldn't see it and even if you
know people are gonna make their
assumptions about two overweight guys
getting in there and fighting the
healthiness that was coming out of you
in that uh video I was just like I've
never seen the side of you I'm so happy
to say that I mean I'm never gonna look
like you I would I would kill to look
like you I don't think genetically in My
DNA but that said I do know that being
healthier is definitely my future
I'll ever be is definitely in my future
I do plan to break that 300 pound
ceiling which is 90 pounds away we got
way in today and I should weigh about
390.
um so I'm a big big boy still got plenty
of fat on me that needs to get burned uh
what was the heaviest you ever win 587
587 pounds that's ridiculous I have no
clue what that is in stone but I was
such a tremendously large dude I was in
a wheelchair for everything I did had to
go to the doctor's office wheelchair if
I had to go to Walmart I got dropped off
at the door I got in the mark cart I
went through Walmart that way and
sometimes uh even at home we had to pull
that wheelchair out I had a walker for
home but even sometimes I had to pull
the wheelchair out just to get around my
house and I did my best to hide that
um because I just felt like you know I
was embarrassed by that aspect but I
mean I just there was a period of time
where one of the reasons my marriage
failed is because my wife became my
caretaker and that's not cool for
anybody who's 29 years old just how old
she wasn't tonight as this one was
literally having to help me sometimes
from the chair to my uh recliner for my
from the chair in the bed I know what he
wants to do that at that age and I'm all
right in thinking that you were
diagnosed with a form of cancer yeah I
have polycythemia vera I took
testosterone supplements starting nine
years ago and it was the injection one
and they told me as I signed up for
they're like there's a remote chance
that you could get a form of cancer for
this very rare it's bone cancer and I'm
like okay I would I would like to grow
muscle I'd like to be able to repair my
heart so since I have no testosterone
otherwise let's do whatever it takes
turns out I was one of the Unlucky few
after seven eight years on the therapy
and it's so frustrating because now I'm
on the he put me back on in preparation
for this fight but now on the topic of
gel
why wasn't I on that one to begin with
because that doesn't seem to have the
same side effects why I'm so confused
that's why we did the engine but
whenever it is what it is
um the prognosis on it is 20 years and
basically at the point I'm at now this
is causing a very elevated red blood
cell count okay so when you say the
prognosis 20th what does that mean most
people who die from it will die on an
average about 20 years from their
diagnosis so you're a 48 year old man
yeah that put me like 60 and I think
I'll be fine okay but this is the modest
thing for me is
you know we've seen some uh
circumstances where people have had
fights before never in my life do I
remember someone who's 48 who's nearly
400 pounds who has cancer and then
they're gonna fight tomorrow well I'm
also not fighting you I don't I'm
fighting Jordy so I'm fighting Wings
it's a it's a bit of a different
experience I'll respect it right and and
this is the thing that people don't
understand is there's a lot of people
out there who wouldn't risk getting in
the ring and who wouldn't have the balls
to do what you're doing and this Wings
guy is 10 years younger than you he's
bigger than you he's got longer arms
than you you know from an outside
perspective he should win this fight
yeah I'm signing up for an ass beating I
knew it when I signed up but here's
Here's my thought process on it because
I had to uh number one I have 30 000
hours worth of implants on my face and
my dentist is not happy about this uh
he's he's like if you can feel a sharp
pain in the fight you have to end it
immediately get on the plane and come to
Dallas immediately so I can fix it you
could lose your implants if one of those
posts break I need to fix it immediately
am I doing okay my doctor I asked him
I'm like can I do this he said you're
asking me the wrong question son I'm
like what's the right question he said
should you do this I'm like well should
I he goes absolutely not I'm like why
and then he listed off a a list of risks
stroke heart attack broken jaw uh do
more damage to the back do more damage
to the knee do all of the things that
could happen to this fight and I'm like
yeah but what if I win
this is the thing about you is you are
the definition of what YouTube for me
was all about to start off with was an
unlikely hero someone who like when when
we wish to watch TV people would never
have gotten an opportunity to have a
huge audience the way you did and for to
be a guy who as you say was wheelchair
bound who had a very hard life to be of
the people's champion no tomorrow when
you're warping down the to that ring you
are the people's Champion bro forget
about winning on losing I I said that
during the press conference yesterday
I'm like I think I already won
absolutely Jordy you might win by
decision and there's no way he's
knocking me out I'm nobody's knocking me
out I'm telling I would take a punch
from you and I'd get back up 90 of the
time I think
um that said uh he might win by decision
but I already won just by being here man
uh I I'm really proud of myself and you
know a lot of people said I think maybe
you're haters or other people even
keemstar said people are gonna have
respect for you again thanks and I'm
glad but at the same time this is I'm
afraid to do this well man just let's be
honest right like this is a scary thing
I don't like getting in the face I
haven't been hitting the face since I
was 18 years old and I want to do it
again right
um I I'm not a big fan of hurting my
money he says Mike Tyson used to say on
the way of the Ring yeah he's scared
yeah you're not human if you're not
scared so yeah just remember that when
you're on the the way it's in order to
be scared but what I want you to do as a
friend okay I just want you to soak it
all up from oh yeah every second because
because that that like that [__]
that you were at school it was bullied
and all of that that you're [__]
showing them do you want to know the
only fight I was ever in prior to this
you want to know what the only one I was
there in so I was in uh high school and
in 10th Grade I was so ashamed of my
body I wouldn't change out for gym class
so I flunked it and then my senior year
they're like you have to take that over
you have to dress out if you would like
to graduate and I definitely wanted to
graduate and go to college so I had to
take 10th grade PE in the 12th grade
again and they were kind of leaning on
me like they understood everything right
um but I was still dressing out every
day and I would go got a little more
confidence I got my first girlfriend I
lost my virginity I don't really care
what other people thought I was starting
to come into my own finally and there's
this one kid in 10th Grade
it just gave me [__] every day see we
would won the softball match if you
weren't so fat and slow and like I the
problem is I'm just so tired I spent the
entire night having sex with your mom
and your dad joined in halfway through I
mean why are you so fat I'm like because
every time I have sex with your mom and
I give her an orgasm she bakes me a pie
and look I don't want to eat all that
pie but I do it because she's so
depressed she has you as a child and she
hates you right you're like I would just
fire back as a comedian thinking I was
like the the bee's knees so one day I
show up at my car and him and his older
brother who's 18 is standing there his
older brother looks at me and goes look
here's what's going to happen my my
brother's gonna beat the [__] out of you
and you're gonna let him and if you hit
him back I'm gonna hit you I'm like okay
like I I was probably getting the
beating when I got home I probably got
one the day before so I went what's the
big deal
um he hit me till he was bored he
eventually broke my glasses and I
remember seeing my glasses like fly off
my face and go to the yard and off the
sidewalk and I started crying then I
said why are you crying because you
broke my glasses man like those are my
mom's gonna kill me I'm actually gonna
get a beating when I get home like I
need black both of my eyes and and it
you know it wasn't great I didn't throw
a single punch back I think that's one
of the things that I'm excited to
actually do tomorrow I've never thought
of myself as a guy that would hit
another guy I've never thought about
even if the guy signed up for it I'm the
guy when I've gone to bars a handful of
my type somebody's is pissed off they
don't like the look of me hey let me buy
you a drink man let me buy you and your
friends a drink I talk my way out of it
if I can't talk my way out of it I get
the hell out of there right I'm not
gonna have a physical altercation with a
person I've been afraid to do it my
whole life
tomorrow's the day and uh I you know
what's fight whether what do they say in
Fight Club what do you know about
yourself if you've never been in a fight
right so let's let's see what kind of
man I am I'm excited to try it you know
what you will learn a lot about yourself
in that moment and and the the thing
about it is is
I understand that you know people may
say oh this is your fault you gained the
way yada yada [__] that right this is
not about that right now it will be
harder for you than it would be for
anybody else in there and and there's
some there's something in that to be
proud of that and that's what I'm
talking about is like if you can just
keep trying no matter what until The
Bitter End every single hater who's
never had the balls to get in there and
do what you're doing will secretly know
inside of them
fair play they can't take that away from
you and I I love that but again for me
the biggest thing is I've learned to try
to tune those people out as best I can
which I'm pretty susceptible to it's
still um based on just who I am as a
person but I learned to tune that out as
best I can whether you like me or love
me I I'm not that interested as much as
I are you watching I I I'm glad you're
entertained right
um if you love me I love you back and if
you hate me I just don't feel anything
about you that's okay you just you do
what you need to do
um but tomorrow or as opposed to earning
their respect I just want to earn my own
man I just want to say
yeah my biggest mistake was given up on
myself my biggest mistake was giving up
on my body my biggest mistake was saying
this is who I am I let's talk
psychedelically again for a minute and I
can't not do it because it's now such a
huge part of how my brain works my
belief structure if my model of the
universe is correct I chose all of these
challenges for myself I said at some
point prior to this life I said I'm
going to be born Stephen Williams I'm
going to be born at this time at this
place to these parents with these
experiences and these challenges and I
want to learn and overcome from
experiencing these things the same way
when you put a video game in your game
system and you you roll up a character
on Grand Theft Auto and you choose which
side quests you're going to do I I
genuinely think that's how the universe
works now and I looked at these
challenges and I said nope not too much
I quit this game I Rage Quit
um now that I know it that it's a game
now that I know and I don't mean I
believe it's a game I'm telling you I
know that this is a game that we are
playing for the experience
I've done two now I've done uh the five
grams of penis enemy mushrooms and then
I did
an unsafe amount of MDMA is probably the
best weight about it
um which was so yeah the way my Shaman
would put it he said that the first
experience was designed to open my mind
chakra and the second experience was to
open my heart chakra and the MDMA
was not a good experience it was a very
bad experience I had to
when they do this in in psychedelic
therapy there's a great documentary on
Netflix for people who are interested in
this stuff and think that might be right
for them it's called how to change your
mind okay
um and with the MDMA you completely lose
your inhibitions especially at the level
that I was at and those inhibitions were
keeping me from being able to admit what
a piece of [__] I bet and out of all the
things that I had to admit oh I hurt my
Audience by torpreting my career I I
hurt my ex-wife by not being good enough
of a husband I I you know I heard but I
hurt myself and that was the one that I
really would never allow myself to think
or feel right
um I had destroyed
the mind and body that I was given to
explore this universe with and to
overcome these challenges with I chose
comfort
over Challenge and what happens when you
when you choose Comfort over pain early
on you still have to deal with the pain
later and I was in so much more pain
because of it my back my knees my wealth
my health all of it was ruined because I
chose this path of least resistance as a
kid I learned now and hopefully for the
next life and the life after that I'll
always know that I'm going to choose to
do the work now do the pain now suffered
now so that my life is better for it
moving forward and if anybody's ever
listening if you ever listened to
anything I've ever said do the work now
so it can be better for you later it's
ironic as well because boxing
is the hardest thing I think you can
probably do in terms of a physical
challenge and it's a metaphor for life
like in life sometimes you're getting
your ass kicked you have to cover up and
take it until it's time to give it back
yeah yeah and and and for me when I
learned out a box
um it's funny because I remember the
first we got it on camera actually the
um
I did a couple of uh documentaries about
learning the Box called the rebuild and
my first ever sparring session where I
had no head God
um and I was getting punched in the face
for the first time yeah yeah uh my
mother passed away when I was younger
and she was my source of like power like
my dig deep and think of I won't give up
because she didn't want me she never
would want me to give up of course and
at the end after I'd had my ass kicked
for about six rounds and I got you know
destroyed as you do I just cried because
I I felt like uh I'd connected with her
in that moment again like I was using
her so much that it was almost like yeah
it's in the room yeah and you know we
all go to different places and it may
surprise you what comes out of you after
that fight but what I do want for you is
for you to use this as like the turning
point and be like if whatever happens
you get your ass kicked whatever this is
the new buggy you know like it's never
too late to change and you're really
making positive steps here I mean it's
pretty clear that I have an addictive
personality absolutely oh whether it's
the the food or the video games or
anything else right and I became
addicted to YouTube at one point you're
a very good addict you you know you
killed it on YouTube and like let's be
real like I once said I put in like 70
hour work weeks yeah people are like
there's no way of course that and I'm
like no of course I did this Ollie I
woke up I breathed ain't slept YouTube
and went to bed and then that's it that
was the entire day was YouTube YouTube
YouTube I chose one day a week to spend
with my wife and one day a week to spend
with my friends but the rest of it and
even most of those days we filmed
something we did something we're headed
adding something why do people why do
these YouTube boxers like like Jake Paul
and KSI for example why are they so good
at boxing why do they like I'm not
saying that they're like the you know
world champion boxers but they get good
very quickly Jake Paul got good very
quickly because they're addicts they're
literally no full-time dedication yeah
so you know you're you're you have that
same YouTube mindset and obviously you
know the stage of life and the
challenges that you have I'm not
expecting you to become Jake Paul but
the point is is that dedication deserves
respect man but my friend uh everybody
knows Dallas Page right um
so one time he said to me he's like bug
I don't know if you'll ever be one of
those people that lose weight like this
guy where I was doing a reaction video
to one of his weight loss inspiration
videos and and I asked him I'm like man
what does it take to be like that and he
goes because I don't know you'll ever be
that kind of person because that kind of
person all he does he wakes up in the
morning he works out he goes to sleep
that's all he does he doesn't have a
wife he doesn't have a family he's not
running a business you're doing all of
those things on top of that and I just
thought man I don't know I don't know if
I could be that person but I think it
could now I think especially as I'm I'm
boxing there's definitely that
adrenaline rush there's a foot aspect of
it I started working out finally after
covid for the first time last year and
got into the pool and I was having so
much fun in the pool
um and I would upload my workouts and
people are like making fun of me like
all you're doing is bobbing in a
plumbing dude I can't stand up of course
I'm bobbing and the pool is the only
thing I can do is laps and [__]
um but that was me getting back from
Kobe because at the end of kovid when I
finally got vaccinated I could barely
walk I didn't do anything for two years
and blow upload YouTube and then live
stream I just sat in my house and played
video games and waited that I was like
well if I'm gonna die any day I'm gonna
spend this time uh you know with my dogs
my friends and playing games and
watching shows because that's what I
want to do uh turns out we didn't die
from kova and the world went on but that
said
it's been I felt a little bit of that
tickle
um and
then with this boxing self I put my bag
right in front of my television it's
right there in the living room every
time I walk by it I'm like let's do two
minutes let's do three minutes let's do
four minutes and it became a matter of
habit and after it became a matter of
habit I remember had my friends over on
a Saturday night and I just wasn't
thinking about it we were all partying
having a good time and I put on my
gloves and started boxing my bag and my
friends were annoyed by it because like
it's kind of obnoxious I'm like I didn't
even think about it I was just I'm just
doing the thing I do all the time now
that's great and I think tomorrow's
going to be a huge adrenaline hit and
positive or negative I I feel like I'm I
could easily be the kind of person that
that gets addicted to that adrenaline
awesome and ironically boxing
it's a computer game you know the all of
the uh fundamentals that you use on a
computer game of energy can uh
conserving letting your energy build
back up for the in a boss battle you
know knowing when to be within range
when to step out of range knowing how to
cover up all all and then no one went
and let your attack go a lot of that is
like gaming and actually uh one of the
best YouTube boxing instructors uh Leon
would break it down just like that for a
Nissan Gib yeah but that's how he kind
of taught him boxing and using gaming
strategy I think
um in terms of your experience up until
now you said you've been hit in the face
is that right yeah we boxed a little bit
spark a little bit and
obviously I did not do very well I was
fighting a skinny person so to begin
with they had all the mobility in the
world I saw your prediction video I
tagged me somebody tagged me on Twitter
I refused to watch it because I knew I
was coming here today I wanted you to
say it to my face yeah oh pretty the due
to win you know really oh yeah yeah for
the reason being when I watched your
Draw My Life video
what you've been through in life
it's a lot harder than people ever give
you credit for I literally just watched
it a day before I interviewed oh damn
man and even thinking about it it makes
me emotional because there's so much
sadness that you've been through in life
and I know what it's like to have had a
life like that where you're watching
people you love struggle and all of that
sort of thing and I thought
if it's possible a win you'll win you're
gonna be very hard to break a lot of
people have asked me like why do you
keep referencing like the child abuse
stuff and it's because when you live
your first 18 years life in a war zone
you don't forget that it becomes part of
who you are it affects trauma affects
your nerves trauma affects your brain
trauma affects your muscle memory and I
feel it's a [__] thing that it have
gone through that and knowing how it
affects me and the person I am to not
tell that to a friend and not tell that
to a partner not tell that to my
audience I want them to know that this
is what shaped me being more specific
about it you've been very open about
your mother was abusive to you and you
were a child
um and your dad was a coal miner some of
the toughest guys who ever existed he
lost all of his Hearing in one year lost
part of the hearing in the other he
shattered his right arm getting trapped
under a boulder he literally was an
electrician and he did that work in
Waist Deep Water water and got shocked
all the time and he kept going in there
to provide for for his family you know a
woman who hated him and beat him and
called him every name in the book and he
still went to work every day these days
oh no and my grandfather the the the
mall the the dad on my mom's side
exactly the same way Dad Carl was one of
the roughest here's my favorite daddy
Carl stories okay so my mom and my dad
uh got married and moved to Cincinnati
Ohio uh from pound Virginia and
um they were there for a little while
when Mom got pregnant and apparently my
dad was originally physically abusive to
her and at some point kicked her in the
stomach while she was pregnant while
drunk one day and so my mom packed up
her [__] and left and came back the
pound and uh my grandfather daddy Carl
decided he was not going to raise that
man's bastard son so he got into His
Cadillac with a shotgun and nothing else
and drove to Cincinnati Ohio knocked on
that apartment door my dad answered
didn't he put that shotgun and Dad's
from my dad's face and says hey Carl how
you doing this well a lot better if you
take that shotgun out of my face they're
both named Carl there's Carl and that
and it's all doing all right Carl if you
take that shotgun on my face because no
I don't suspect a will
so yeah Carla got a question for you do
you want to come back home and raise
your son or do you want to die where
you're standing because I guess I'll
come home with you and let me pack a few
things because no we got everything you
need and pound get in the car and they
drove his ass home uh that's daddy
Colonel for you and that's my that's my
dad on top of that my dad didn't Flinch
he's just like oh hey how are you let's
just do the thing we got to do so I I do
think I don't know if I'm anywhere near
as tough as either of those men but I do
think it's in my blood to some degree
I'm telling you it is by the way but the
thing I learned during my first
psychedelic trip is that the challenges
are the fun part oh yeah okay so like
can I get can I just completely peel
back the Psychedelic North for it if
this doesn't resonate with anybody it's
because you don't need this okay if it
sounds like [__] to you it's because
it might be okay so that said here's
what I think I experienced okay
um I took the shrooms and like in the
first 30 minutes it was like eating
Edibles like ah THC or whatever and like
oh kind of a goofy time and my my Sean
was like can you see the fractals yet
and I realized I could I could see like
the fractals that make up the universe
or whatever and he's like close your
eyes you'll throw pills yeah psychedelic
patterns as these oh yeah it was not the
geometric ships right right and but like
it's so literally that wall would be
made up of this bottle made what you
would be made up of it everything is
made up of it but the world is like
overlaid on top of those for me and so
he's like close your eyes you'll still
be able to see him and here's where I
know some magic [__] was happening I
closed my eyes and I had a cameraman and
a a director there for the documentary
because they're filming this and I can't
see them the moment I close my eyes they
are out of view but I can still see the
fractals that make up the world and I
can see my Shaw and I could see my dog
and I asked my Shaw and I'm like why can
I still see you with my eyes closed
because I'm here with you Boogie I'm
rolling with you right now where to get
here together I'm like why can I see
your dog he's like because they're
always here they're dogs man that didn't
make any sense to me but he hit play on
his [__] Boombox and I think it was
like butthole servers or something and I
died I left my body and I don't mean my
out-of-body experience floated above
myself I mean I went back to where we
come from wow um and that apparently is
different for everybody uh you have the
very
experiences that you have on this life
is so it's going to tailor the
experience to the character you are to
help the transition I apparently needed
not much of anything so I just got
jumped into the ether I saw the energy
that we are all made up of it looked
like a DNA strand of my reflex it
appeared Gray from a distance but as I
got closer to it it's always made out of
like black and white energy and stuff
and then I came back to my body and
pissed myself but wow this guy literally
it's in the documentary I literally
pissed myself
um and that's how I know I was dead
because I like I was dead enough to not
control my own bowels uh but so I come
back and the knowledge that I brought
with me is that and this is so wild I
know how it sounds I don't like to use
the word crazy but people think it's
crazy when I discovered the number one
UI are the same person I hope you know
that but also so is the universe and so
is every animal we eat and all the air
we breathe and the table that I'm
touching right now and the ground we're
sitting on we're all that and we're all
we're all each other so every time I've
heard another person I've hurt myself
and every time I help another person I
help myself and that's a great guiding
tool and if you don't believe that then
apply it to humanity think well we're
all humans at least that right so I
should help others and not hurt others
simple but that's one of the reasons
we're here and then I found out the
entity that we all are is that we're
we're God man
we are I'm only laughing because
I heard Dorian Yates uh talk about this
now Dorian uh is a world champion
bodybuilder yeah yeah so he isn't the
guy who you'd put with what you're
saying yeah and like you know you juice
heads you'd think that they wouldn't
have the he did this whole experience
now dorian's a very intelligent
scientific guy to be favorable he said
exactly word for word what you're saying
he said everything is one and one is
everything yeah and we are all God and
basically here's the coolest thing about
nobody told me what to expect I never
read a book I never talked to a person
mashama didn't prepare me
um everybody that goes there near death
experience meditation psychedelics or
maybe you reach Enlightenment just one
day while you're doing dishes because
that happens to people we always come
back with the same message I genuinely
think it has to be true you could say
it's just the drug but some people do it
through meditation some people get there
through from literally just waking up
one day at night and so I genuinely but
the the other thing that I came back
with I don't know that everybody shares
this is that the negative aspects of
Life are just as joyous to the God we
are as the positive that's why children
get cancer that's why we go through
hardships that's why I have our heart
broken that's why the world sucks
because it's a [__] game we the god
that we are doesn't take it that serious
we take it seriously because we have a
character to play we take it serious
because we erase all of our knowledge to
become Boogie to become Steve Jeff
whoever the hell you are that's the joy
and I think the more I've really thought
on this I think the God we are is born
out of his [__] mind they're they are
eternal and so they are experiencing
they created this and experienced it out
of boredom and and I want to have I
think there's also growth to be done I
think there's also lessons to be learned
um I think there's empathy to be learned
and there's a great video by kurzat on
YouTube I think that's how you pronounce
it called the egg theory and I think
it's very close to that in in reality
which is to say a god experiencing this
world over and over in order to learn
how to be a god I've heard that before
if uh we are Consciousness experience in
itself over and over again yeah yeah
could have made you look back and feel
guilt or tremendously yeah I know I know
guys who've had these trips who for me
seem like the least likely guys to have
an epiphany like the least yeah right
like Jim goes who are just like
Meatheads like and they're like break
down crying telling me the story yeah
about how they realized all of the
errors of their ways and how they wanted
to apologize to everyone they ever heard
and like was it a bit like that for you
or with the MDMA it was for sure uh the
first trip was about knowledge in this
second trip was again again about my
heart I'll tell you what
I I don't know how authentication even
should be today but I've definitely
heard people I love I definitely
disappointed my ex-wife tremendously um
I don't want you to have to be a
caretaker and I shouldn't have been
obsessed with the job the way I was and
I I hate that I broke her heart
and I look back at every relationship
and every friendship I've ever had and
the ones that ended they a lot of times
they didn't then greet I definitely hurt
my share of people all right remember
the the I believe her name was Dez yeah
yeah uh I remember when you got with her
and it was such a like a cute love story
that we were all sort of watching from
the outside because you know it was this
this unlikely hero who you were with her
yeah the guy got the girl and the girl
was out of his league and it was a cute
moment and she looked after you and
everything looked great and yeah it was
it was very sad when I heard that you
guys were separating and obviously
everything happens for a reason but it
does seem like yo you've got a real
heavy heart about the whole thing no I I
do especially after psyched dogs at the
time I think
my I think my ego was in the way and I
think I was very much about like look
the one thing I'm good at doing is
making money so let me do that let me do
the job let me do the work help me do
the work right
um probably one of the most frustrating
fights we ever had she came into the
living room one day and she's like I'm
I'm frustrated because I have to be the
both the man and the woman of the
household and the response I had was
horrific the response I should have had
which was
I understand and I understand your pain
let me hug you let me feel you let me
let me help right what I said instead is
I let my ego get in the way and I'm like
look you don't have to do any of those
things I make enough money to where if
you want the house cleaned we'll pay to
get it cleaned if you want the lawn done
we'll pay to get the lawn done what are
you mad about what are you complaining
no you didn't you didn't give her the
time to listen and really go there with
no I got defensive and I I took it as an
ego stroke and you go blowing I'm like
you know what and like of course you you
know I we needed we were never going to
work long term I mean that's just the
reality of it I think I knew that when
we first got together I think some
people you meet when you're supposed to
meet them and they leave when there's
when you're supposed to leave and I knew
a year before we got divorced that this
was not going to work there's one thing
I'm learning though and I don't know if
you'll agree with this but I feel like
in order for us to make good husbands or
good wives we kind of need taught how to
do that and I think part of the problem
like you know no one no one becomes the
boxer overnight like people just think
you're supposed to know how to be a
husband or a wife or and I think that
the defensive childish state of mind
that you were in is extremely common in
society nowadays because
we're not really
uh given those guidelines that people
had a hundred plus years ago where it
was like the man is this the woman is
this clear defined rules right it now in
especially in your condition in your job
I think about my model though also like
think about the household like of course
right even mostly and so like I'm
guessing at what is the correct thing
I'm trying to walk the balance between
being a complete pushover but also
trying to save my ground because it's
not sexy to be a complete pushover of
course you're going to lose your woman
every time that you let him walk all
over you so I'm trying to figure out
where the correct boundaries are and I
was just not doing it correctly
um and so it was it was a [__] show but
I will say the one thing that I think I
really
learned to regret
um is is having destroyed my own body I
think that is because I have to live
with that mistake for the rest of my
life you know I lose the weight that's
great I'm still gonna look like a an
empty sack of potatoes man you have the
skin removed I
I was expensive for sure it's full
control yeah but that's a dangerous ass
surgery a lot of people who get the
bariatric surgery lose the weight get
the skin removed and they die from the
recovery from that and that [__] happens
um and then there's the back pain and
the knee pain I mean my discs are fused
man in the back L3 and o4 are fused
together now that's that's they're never
coming apart that's not how bone works
is it not you know in this new positive
frame of mind
to just try and make the absolute best
of life that's exactly it and so that is
the because that's where I was trying to
lead
um I was filled with such tremendous
regret
and I had no more excuses during that
second trip I I my ego was gone my
defensiveness was gone all I could do
was accept what I had done wrong
and uh I cried like a child and then I
got mad at myself and I had him record
myself and I yelled at myself I'm like I
know when you are no longer high you're
not gonna be able to feel these feelings
let me feel them for you let me tell you
exactly the kind of piece of [__] you
are
and I told myself you just you've heard
a lot of people but you've hurt yourself
so tremendously and by hurting yourself
you've hurt so many people and my son is
not even faced by this he does this [__]
three five times a day okay yeah it's
ridiculous in her class so this is just
like
to him this is just like another this is
like breakfast you know uh but we're
ending the session and I'm coming down
from rolling and and you don't really
trip on MDMA but I think it's still the
effect is leaving my body and he's like
all right what do we learn I don't like
that I've been a real piece of [__]
and because yeah yeah we all are though
that's okay
um he's like but what are you gonna do
moving forward and I'm like dude I have
to help people don't I and you see yeah
Steve you're a people man
I'm like what he goes if you want to
help people help yourself dude start
with you and he says the reason I've
chosen you to work with is because you
are in such a unique position that if
you help yourself you will help Millions
who've watched you who've grown up with
you who suffered like you if you get
your [__] together they will get their
[__] together that's why you're here so
I don't want you worrying about anyone
else but you it's time to be selfish
and I'm like okay man and that was
seven weeks ago eight weeks ago and it's
just before me and Keem finalized that
this fight was gonna happen and then
here we are you all capable of
influencing people and inspiring you
literally sent me a tweet in 2014 when I
first did a video or something like that
maybe 2015 latest just saying like you
are great you can do this you will
succeed like those words from you in
that one tweet I remember specifically
getting that treatment like [__] me the
guy I've been watching for two years or
whatever it was said that well you
aren't very good at this you know that
I'm obviously your audience knows doing
well but early on yeah but when you
don't have the success I didn't I think
I had like 10 000 subscribers
that meant everything
meant a lot so you have that ability and
that power to influence people in Impact
lives especially because you are so
famous for struggling with what you're
struggling with and the one thing I do
want to say in regards to your
challenges is he's right the shaman guy
everyone's [__] up everyone hurts
people everyone makes mistakes your
mistakes are just more visible because
you wear them yeah and I I mean I also
chose to share it to the very I
overshared for sure good yeah and like
there's no shame in that either I don't
see the point in hiding because the
people who present is perfect are
usually the biggest [__] horrible
[__] oh I can assure you yeah I can
definitely assure you I I've known a few
yeah and unfortunately those little
mistakes as well that you get canceled
for or whatever people do try and pin
that on you pitch and hold you that's
all you want you know you're way more
than that right and I think that what
I'm saying from you is like a different
Boogie and a much more positive place
like oh yeah I I was in a very negative
place after my bypass surgery and after
my divorce I did not knew who I was or
what I was going to be outside of the
marriage I definitely had lost access to
my drug of choice which was food and
then I still had to do my drug of choice
three times a day and I was supposed to
do it responsibly [__] that's hard and
then uh that's what makes food addiction
most guys so anything for me is that
because if you say well heroin or an
alcoholic oh but by the way you have to
have one like one glass of beer three
times a day but you're not allowed to
get hammered right it's very difficult
right exactly
um
but then the internet turned against me
and it all it started kind of small but
I signal boosted it but it started with
like a little subreddit and like oh I
think Boogie's actually a piece of [__]
I think Boogie's actually an abusive
person I actually think Boogie does this
and Boogie does that and like I would
like respond to that because it really
bothered me one of the things that
really bothers me I I shouldn't put this
on the internet but I will because I
overshare everything people are like why
do you always talk when somebody accuses
you of being abusive why do you talk
about that because I hated the cycle God
damn it and it was not easy okay I chose
to get the therapy I chose to do the
work I chose to practice with my
partners I chose to be a [__] doormat
in most of the relationships I was in
out of fear that I would hurt another
person with my feelings my thoughts my
words or God forbid ever my fists right
I never was going to do that to another
person I chose not to do it I wasn't
going to have kids so I wouldn't [__]
them up okay I made one of the biggest
sacrifices somebody can make you think I
didn't want kids I say that all the time
I didn't want kids I [__] wanted kids
more than anything but I couldn't do it
responsibly so I had to pretend I didn't
want them and so I have a legacy a
48-year legacy of ending the cycle I
have a eight nine long-term
relationships that lasted multi-years
and there was never an abusive word
spoken in them I've had women scream in
my face and me not react because I'm out
of fear of the type of reaction I would
have I am so [__] proud that I ended
the cycle
and people now the internet thinks I
didn't I never [__] me up oh it [__]
me up every day like that's why you take
it personal to me and the worry when
you're when you become someone like that
is one day you do snap that's a fearful
thing because if you take so much [__]
from family from spouses from and you're
constantly thinking I just need to not
react not react you know people like
that'll explode one day all the time and
you know thank God you haven't well so I
recently got diagnosed with autism and
uh also as a child was diagnosed with
post traumatic stress disorder from the
childhood and I I will I will have the
occasional meltdown but my meltdown does
not isn't very much not abusive if I'm
abusing anybody it's me I tend to do
this autistic move which is a very
common thing hit myself when they had to
like self-regulate I'll self-harm if you
ever see me like VidCon or a lot of
things I used to wear a rubber band
around my wrist so I could self-harm
that way as a way to self-regulate and
most of the time when a partner or a
friend was like very upset with me my
autistic meltdowns often resulted in
I'll let me I'll act one out right now
like [__] get away from it you just
gotta get the [__] away from me leave me
the [__] alone I cannot talk about this
I do not want to [__] talk about it
get the [__] away from me right that was
my form of autistic meltdown and that
can in itself be abusive like that's a
shitty way to speak to anybody I don't
want to have spoke to anybody that way
but it sure be what my parents did each
other well you know it's very normal uh
I'm familiar with autism and it is a
very understandable and normal reaction
um and I feel like
at the end of the day I I always wanted
to do better than that but I've begun to
understand that my my worst was still
pretty goddamn good considering the
circumstances but also considering just
your average person I had somebody talk
to me on
I saw this Stephen Crowder clip that's
going around and it's where he's like
going off on his wife right he's eight
month pregnant wife and he's doing in my
opinion my analysis of it is he's
he's setting up a no-win situation for
her as a form of narcissistic abuse he's
he's like oh she's like well I want to
go do the thing well you can't do the
thing well I'll go take the car then you
can't have the car well then I'll get a
ride with somebody else well you can't
do that either
well he's just making the problem
unsolvable as a form of I've been in a
situation with a woman before where she
said those things together right exactly
right and and that is certainly if you
feel like there's no way out yeah uh and
so she does exactly what you do in that
situation which is there's no pleasing
you I just I'm just gonna go sit down
and shut down because that's what you
[__] do uh and I'm looking at this
clip and I'm like
I've never spoken to a person like that
I've never done anything like that I'm
so [__] proud that I'm better as a
person than Stephen Crowder was in that
woman I I in that moment I can't speak
to Stephen Crowder in every other moment
I don't know if he's like an abusive
shitty person I'm not trying to say that
I'm saying in that one moment I've never
been that person I've never been that
bad I feel you on that because as
Internet personalities people become
very familiar with us and they they
identify the hours of content with that
must be them all the time or that one
mistake that they hold into and me too
man I've been through
um a lot of [__] life a lot of ups
and downs and I'm very proud of who I am
actually despite the mistakes I've made
I'll look back and I think the amount of
people I've helped in my life the amount
of uh friendship and money and
everything I could possibly give anyone
loyalty protection you name it and when
people get this opinion of you in there
just hold on to it as if they're an
offer of [__] and it's oh yeah if you'd
actually watched my life take a walk in
my issues you'd be stunned I'm even
alive let alone succeed oh yeah I
remember to a lot of people on the other
side of these cameras we ain't people
okay we're ants and and farm we're fish
in a fish bowl we ate people okay and
secondly some of them lack the critical
thinking to think outside of the thing
that they've heard or the thing that
they immediately believed then there's
cognitive dissonance they don't want to
disagree in their own head maybe I was
wrong about that person they don't even
want to have that thought of that
feeling or owner identify something you
started doing with people in their own
life and they attribute your whole
personality
and it's so much scarier when they're
projecting themselves onto you they
[__] hate themselves and you share a
treat with themselves then they're gonna
hate you ten times worse than they ever
should because they're afraid to hate
themselves right
um I saw swings as one of his one of his
uh um
detractors or whatever you call them got
docs the other day and he's like always
calling flings how fat and disgusting
Wings is dudes fatter and wings
and and I'm like of course he's just
projecting all right
um I've had a lot of hatred and I'm I'm
sure that the things that they are
saying they themselves have issues with
yeah and I'm all for
healthy criticism all right like hey
boogie you're [__] up in your career
you are correct you should definitely
lose some weight you are [__] correct
okay I haven't signed my dick in so long
I can have it declared legally dead I
would like to I would like to lose my
weight yeah um that's a true story by
the way you know in fact I haven't seen
my dick in so long I literally could
have it declared legally done but the
other day I was taking a gesture and I I
was looked down in the toilet and I
heard a little clunk as I was pissing
and I'm like did I just piss a kidney
stone whoa I look down in the toilet and
floating is a tiny little bottle with a
tiny little cork in it I take the cork
out and I pull out a tiny little note
and you know what the note said the Rose
said
hey I'm still on here I miss you
sincerely your dick P.S please send
[__] so I know he's alive you know he's
still doing something right you
mentioned before yeah about doxing and
all of that yeah I've got to bring the
the moment where you became internet
famous once again a guy comes to your
door
those are [__] viral for of you with
me yeah it's it's it was like the one of
my favorite things ever on the internet
like that picture of you just pointing
this good at this guy like it was just
what the [__] so I think a lot of people
don't know the full story about that and
maybe even you don't I'm not properly no
like so one day I'm live streaming and I
don't even bother say the guy's name you
look it up if you want to
um but they they start saying his name
and channel like this person's coming to
harass you he's coming to your house
he's gonna [__] kill you and I'm like
what I don't even know who this person
is you got his YouTube channel deleted
I'm like I what I never heard of this
person what are you talking about
and so I find him on Twitter and I DM
them I'm like hey man somebody says
you're like coming to my house to harass
me or whatever is that true he's like no
man I'm just a comedian it's okay
I'm like okay cool all right
um and then he starts getting weird like
he's sending like photos of the Joker
because he thinks he's the Joker or
something and so I reach out to a few
mutuals keemstar Ethan Ralph people like
that it gives you an idea who the
mutuals are right
um and I'm like what do you know about
this guy like oh he's a comedian he's
just gonna clown on you or whatever and
I'm like cool Ethan's like come on my
podcast I'll squash the beef and I'm
like
every time I've ever been on Ethan's
podcast it turns out poorly but I'm an
idiot and I'm bored during kovitz let's
go so I pop into the podcast and the guy
at first is like doing all the usual
clowning stuff oh you're fat don't you
pay for sex workers don't you do all
this other [__] yeah sugar get over here
this [__] that's how I recover from
my marriage I have no shame in that and
um with that said
at some point in the thing he's like
look but yeah I don't think you
understand I'm coming to your house and
when I do I'm gonna [__] you up it's
gonna be the worst day of your life
it'll be worse than the day your parents
[__] molested you I'm willing to ruin
you and I was like cool if you come here
I'll [__] kill you
so six weeks later he gets on a plane
and flies in the middle of a pandemic
from his home in Atlanta Georgia to
Fayetteville Arkansas and studies starts
taking photos from my neighborhood
tweeting them at me I mean you're
telling you fat f-a-d-g-o-t what are you
gonna do about it dudes obsessed with
like homosexual serves for some reason
we'll get into that but I I'm so
confused and so again I reach out to
keemstar I'm like this dude's in my town
you guys told me this was not gonna be a
thing you guys told me he was a comedian
he said I let him clown on you it's not
even that big of a deal I'll put you on
the show today and this is after like
two days of him being in the town
tweeting [__] at me I haven't slept
we've been checking our doors and
windows all night okay I've called the
cops the cops have already visited the
cops told me if he shows up kill him if
he tries to come in your house kill him
shoot him you have every right to
protect yourself I'm like okay so I've
got that in my head so I go on this
podcast and I have a complete meltdown
and I'm like I can't wait till you come
to my house you've been in my town for
two days why didn't you come here yet
I'm gonna bury you I'm gonna watch you
bleed out of my front lawn because I'd
had enough man and like I said earlier I
don't know where to draw the line so I'm
trying to figure out where to draw it
and that old southern coal miners coming
out of me that's what Daddy Carl would
have said that's what Dad would have
said so that's what I'm saying in the
situation I know since my brother's dad
similar situation so my brother would
have said so summer to act like they do
because that's the correct thing to do
in this award them away it did not warn
them away so the next day he shows up at
my front door and I literally have like
an air conditioning guy there I was not
expecting we thought he'd come in the
night like a thief we didn't expect to
show up in the morning and he starts
filming in my front yard I guess uh but
eventually knocks on the door and it's
like answer the door you fat f-a-g-o-t
the two things he liked to call me
during that altercation he liked to call
me homosexual slurs and he also called
me the n-word now here's the thing about
calling me a homosexual slur I could be
a closeted homosexual that is a thing I
could be I could wake up in the morning
and suck a dick I am not going to wake
up in the morning and be black
why the n-word that still confuses me to
this day who's he doing he's very
confusing just overall right So
eventually I answered the door because I
realize uh boy I'm glad the court case
is over because I can't say this [__]
any other way but I'm like I I'm like I
have to do something here I have to
stand up for myself here this man's on
my property he's been harassing me for
months this is not okay and I need to do
something about it and I know how the
internet's going to take it I know the
internet's going oh it's a fat Boogie
with a gun isn't that the pushover
another [__] or I told you he was
actually an abuse I know in my mind but
I'm going on gut reaction I have to
stand up for myself I have to finally
[__] do it so I answered the door
with a gun and put the gun in his face
and I told him to leave I don't want to
hurt you you gotta go and he does his
bid you know if you're gonna use that
gun you should put it right here and
pull the [__] trigger kill yourself
and stuff like that and I'm like the
whole time like man I want to have to
kill anybody today but I'm so glad to
kill you you gotta go you gotta go you
gotta go
um and eventually I think he said that
it wasn't a real gun or at least that's
what I remember I've never watched the
tape uh he had a GoPro strapped to his
head and uh I I he's like you really
gonna kill me and I'm like oh I'd rather
a fire warning shot first
I guess it fired now so I took a step
forward I fired the warning shot knowing
full well what's west of my house which
is the woods knowing that that bullet
would land in the woods then no one was
at rest no one was going to get hurt
um and it worked he uh stopped laughing
he stopped clowning he realized that he
was in Mortal danger and then he said go
[__] yourself Inward and then turn
around and walked away
I don't know arrested for that yes
because there's a mug shot yeah I about
a year later
the boy again a D.A in Arkansas I'm
sorry but I'm gonna tell the truth and I
hope it does I hope it does come back on
me uh but originally they had no
intention of charging me because I'm the
victim in that situation they know I'm
the victim in that situation and then
six or five people got shot in Northwest
Arkansas in like a six week period
and the they basically got told that
both Benton County and Washington County
had to look tough on gun crime and I was
a very high profile case so they were
going to throw the book at me
and that's apparently what the da told
my lawyer and that's what my lawyer told
me so he decided to make an example of
me because it was such a hard profile
case and the vice media was going to
cover it and all that what it what does
it feel like when you're getting you're
getting booked in uh by the cops yeah
and they recognized me as a YouTuber and
they were really nice to me actually oh
really there's nothing about it but at
the same time look you've been through a
[__] ton yeah you're now on this part of
this journey where
after everything you're you're literally
going to be taken down charged all of
that like what the hell has gone through
your mind at that point I was Jerry
Smith from Rick and Morty do you watch
the show Rick and Morty you're familiar
with Jerry's math and I'll see you in a
few or there's if you're not familiar
with character
um he's intentionally pathetic and at
some point in the episode uh both Rick
and a therapist tell him you use it as a
defense mechanism you choose to be as
pathetic as you could possibly be and I
realized I'm Jerry Smith I was choosing
to be the most pathetic pushover [__]
of a person that I could be I'm a victim
no one would want to victimize a victim
would they I've already been through it
why would you want to hurt me I've
already been hurt turns out that
sociopaths when they find out you're a
victim they realize they can victimize
you so that's what they do it turns out
that shitty people will be shitty to
victims they've already been victimized
once they're used to it I can take
advantage of this person I can hurt this
person they'll deal with my [__]
sociopathic uh Partners look for doormat
Partners exactly this is the vegan walk
all over and they'll put up with your
[__] absolutely and so by wearing
that on my sleeve I thought it would
protect me it does not it absolutely
makes you a target with the wrong group
of people and that person that came to
my front door saw that and chose to take
advantage of that and uh you know at the
end of the day the last I heard you know
I'm out here boxing in London last night
I heard he was working at a gas station
I don't know if that's true or not this
I've got him blocked on everything
um but I at least I survived it I know
when you Google that person's name a
photo of me comes up how sad must that
be
I mean I completely respect the
directions in that moment I'm like [__]
yeah I always wanted to say that but my
lawyer
um told me that I can't but and now I
can tell you 100 I stood up for myself
yeah no one should be on my [__]
property no one should be there to
harass me the dude who was talking about
taking me in my house and [__] me in
my ass we don't talk we'll talk to
another person like that I don't care if
you think it's funny I don't think he'd
care if it's interesting I don't think
if you care I think I deserve it I also
deserve stand up for myself to arm
myself to protect myself when someone I
don't know if that guy's got a gun you
know I don't know if that guy's enough
if you'd have shot him I wouldn't have
thought twice about oh I would have
probably not been arrested if I shot him
that's the interesting thing about the
Arkansas laws at that particular time
and I shot and killed him and to snatch
that GoPro from his head I wouldn't have
been an ounce of trouble it's the fact
that I endangered a neighbor's life uh
that's the one I charged for I got
charged with aggravated assault not
against him [__] him oh yeah I got I saw
I aggravated assault because that bullet
had to come down somewhere and it's
possible
though statistically unlikely based on
the MythBusters it would come down near
where a person is and if it hit a person
it might have hurt them statistically
0.0001 chance for something like that
but regardless that's what they hit me
with Yeah you mentioned the dating life
and that sort of thing yeah what's
happening with that because you know as
a guy on the internet you things have
been all right for you well how into
that do you really want to get because
I'll go oh I want to go all the way I
don't know what's going on because what
the thing is is men not different right
we're able to get women we probably
shouldn't be able to get when income is
higher a sense of humor is bad it's not
were you doing this is the thing we
don't judge women the way women uh judge
us and vice versa right so yeah so my
first girlfriend came at me hard and
fast and I would never really couldn't
understand why it turns out in
retrospect she told me it's because I
was the only person in Upper bound who
didn't treat her just like a sex object
because she was very well endowed in the
in the for chest area and uh most guys
are like grabbing on her talking to her
shitty and I was just like hey let's be
friends and she's like wow that's so hot
uh so she's the one that lost my
virginity Believe It or Not uh
15 when we met 16 we lost my virginity
and we dated off and on until I was
22-23 and then we broke it off I did
seven years of playing World of Warcraft
and never leaving my house and she did
she got married during that period of
time and was married to that man until
she passed away about five years ago uh
how was that for you it was really hard
it was a really hard time
um we stayed very very close and uh
I'll never forget our last conversation
uh she had breast cancer and then uh the
breast cancer got treated by chemo as
well as a double mastectomy and that
chemo led to brain cancer led to lung
cancer which moved into her brain and
killed her very quickly uh so we thought
she was out of the the Woodworks and
next thing you know she's dying
and so I went to see her and her husband
and hung out with him and we said our
goodbyes knowing that she'd be that
within the next couple of months but
I she was having trouble even talking
then and I I would still routinely call
her and then share herself with her and
um I talked to her about a week before
she passed and uh
uh during the conversation it was really
hard to talk to her she's not able to
make a lot of sense but yes if I'd send
her a care package and I would routinely
do that and just goofy stuff sometimes
video games and stuff like that she's
like she said what am I doing dying
alone here having to talk to you in a
week and I'm like God Andy yo
um and then like we bullshitted about
that stuff and
and then I'm like hey did I ever tell
you I'm how sorry I am for the [__] we
put each other through as kids
and she said yeah I think every time
we've ever talked
and she's like did I ever say I was
sorry too and I'm like no I don't think
you ever did that's nice thanks Steve
it's nice to hear that she's like
yeah I'm [__] dying huh because I'm
like yeah and she was dead a week later
that Amazon package arrived about the
day before she died we shoplifted a lot
as kids because we didn't have anything
you know and she was obsessed with these
little rubber band balls called Koosh
balls and I sent her one uh from Amazon
just like as an old time thing and she
died so all she was holding up
and uh it's so final isn't it Matt
yeah it [__] me up to this day man but
uh you know she ultimately had a pretty
happy life and she once said that we
worked our crazy out on each other so we
would be better for the people that were
in our futures and
always be grateful for that you know
because I we didn't hurt each other
quite a bit
uh nothing like the internet seems to
think as capable of me but we she
cheated and and I didn't know how to
handle it and I wasn't good at
controlling my autism or my meltdowns or
anything like that and I couldn't be a
great boyfriend sometimes and
the fact that you are still there for
her all the way bro I think that's
commendable that's really lovely there's
very few women I've I mean I I was
texting my ex-wife last night before bed
and we're sharing photos and I mean
she'll be my friend for the rest of my
life I think once I've Loved Someone I
I'm never going to stop loving you on
some level am I not romantically love
you anymore that's a different thing but
there's that familial love and I think
it's because I didn't have much of a
family for myself so once you come into
my life and you've made an impact you've
helped me build my business like my
ex-wife did or he helped me through my
mental health issues like my first
girlfriend did or or hell we just had a
really good time
um I'm gonna owe you something for the
rest of my life and there's there's not
a woman I've ever dated who's afraid to
call this phone except one I think
there's one uh and if they call does he
need a ride to the airport you're going
to get you need uh near to listen you're
going to get you need advice you'll get
used to if I had money back for when I
had a lot more money you get money if
you need that just whatever you need man
I'm here I'm here to help because you
helped me
I think that's such a healthy way to
view it every relationship I've ever had
is like
oh a jigsaw puzzle right you're trying
to make the pieces fit and some of them
don't always fit and sometimes the piece
is so important you're like this isn't
going to work uh-huh right so we just
got to go do different things that's how
it was with an ex-wife right I married
her when she was very young uh she's 23.
uh and then seven years later we're
we're like Hey we're both very different
people and I'm going through a new
change for the bariatric surgery and
everything else so I'm going to be a
very different person do we fit anymore
no we do not this is not how it was
supposed to be this is not what we
signed up for let's go see if we can be
happier and as far as I can tell I I'm
certainly happier and she seems happier
so I think everybody won at the end of
the day
um I think it's very mature to be able
to look at her my ex-wife said she's
like I think it's time we separated and
I'm like yeah yeah I really don't want
that she's like yeah but I think it's a
good idea to do it now
uh while I still love you
I think that's a really nice way to put
it yeah all right that [__] me up at
the time like but if you still love me
that's what we should be fighting for
right that's the same thing she doesn't
want to resent you in the long run yeah
but that's what it was only going to
come down to is that uh every
relationship waxes and wanes and we we
were at a a waxing point it was it was a
very full loving relationship still and
here she was helping me at the surgery
but we knew we weren't working and like
let's let's do this while we're still
polite to each other we can just sign
one piece of paper and walk away instead
of like drag him out in court and be
miserable and hating each other I
definitely remember your video that you
made announcing it and I remember
feeling like okay he seems together he
it doesn't seem like it's chaos right
now there's like horrible bad blood oh
and then credit to her for helping you
through the surgery and not just
abandoning you yeah we had that
conversation about a month before the
surgery
um I'm she's like I I we're not working
anymore and I'm like I know
and and she's like I don't know what
we're supposed to do I'm like I think we
probably separate after my surgery
um but I'm like you if you stick me
through this you get me through I can't
do it without you no I can't I can
barely function without you now so save
my life like do me that favor she's like
of course I'm gonna do that of course
I'm gonna do that all right though
that's really good and she did uh and I
mean how would I not be there for that
person forever yeah you you go back and
look at my YouTube career how many bad
things have I said about there's plenty
of bad things I could say about
everybody right there's definitely bad
things I could say about her what if I
said that was bad what what juicy detail
I ever had about no I'm never going to
I'll protect that woman until I'm dead
in terms of after her you said that you
went on a bit of a period where you were
just having Rhonda like these girls
coming in and you were paying for girls
so here's the story uh another YouTuber
uh and I that were friends obviously
will not talk about who it is they're
like have you ever heard about this
website called seeking arrangements and
I'm like
no what is that because what do you know
what sugaring is I'm like never heard of
it it's like okay so do you like
beautiful women I'm like yes I was like
do you like spending time with beautiful
women yes
do you have money and I'm like are you
talking about escorting he goes no it's
very different from that
I'm gonna go talk to me about how it's
different it's like escorting it's about
the sex you're there for the sex so show
brings about an emotional connection a
friendship connection sometimes they're
sex
but not every relationship because when
I go to these things I like to go to
nice dinners I like to go to my shows
and I like to be there with a beautiful
person
sometimes I have sex with them sometimes
I don't it's up to them
and I'm like [__] I like to go to the
nice dinners I don't know and I sure
would like to look at a beautiful woman
while I do it uh so I [__] logged
into the website the next day
um and the very first girl I dated was
like you explain what the like what you
were experiencing because I'm trying to
get an idea of like okay boogie logs in
is there like a catalog of girls serious
it was really hot at the time like GQ
and all these like magazines and like
websites for talking about sugaring at
the time and so there's a lot of people
that are signing up for it and so
there's literally just a it's tender
basically but for sugaring and and you
read the profiles and they'll tell you
what their expectations are and some
women are you know we'll put platonic
and not no intimacy and they'll give the
type of experiences they're looking for
that what they want to do I want to be
your arm candy I want to go to this
place I take me to this dinner take me
to this show
um you're like cool I'm going to that
show anyway I'm going to that dinner
anyway would you like to go with me can
I be your partner great you know they're
not their return and stuff like that
that's always there because of like just
the legality of it everybody wants to be
very hush-hush and careful about that
you're not supposed to discuss that
stuff that's for when you meet up and
start talking do they say what they're
willing to do physically on their
profile pretty pretty regularly yeah and
so you know who you're getting involved
with and my only thought process was
always
um hey sex is great but I don't I'm
definitely not demisexual um but I do
think I was up man demisexual means you
have to have a an intelligent connection
or or an emotional connection with
somebody to be able to find them
attractive I'm definitely not that I can
look at a beautiful woman and say that
woman is beautiful you're a mom but
whether or not I'm willing to get naked
in front of that person is a whole other
[__] story because I look like the
Stay Puft Marshmallow Man has been left
out in the sun okay so before I'm going
to inflict that on another human being
we better have a [__] connection all
right yeah and so that that was my
process I was like man I just want to go
have nice dinners with beautiful women
and it'll help me feel better and uh
turns out that a lot of these women I
learned
um men and men in your 20s you [__]
suck guys especially in Arkansas uh
they're all about hookup culture they're
all about doing the least amount that
they can they don't want to spend any
money they don't want to go anywhere
they don't want to do anything they want
to come over put on Netflix pretend to
watch it while they [__] you and leave
and that's what every woman's story is
on that list however however no I find
this interesting because I'm really
learning quite a lot about hookup
culture and why is it becoming the thing
right and
I think it's a 50 50 thing as well
because I feel like
men will men will get away with what
they can't as well there's a little bit
of course yeah yeah and I feel like
women are changing as well so like women
are becoming more manly
um uh in a in their sexualization you
know like in terms of the way they're
behaving to right right so
men do suck but women also are
changing a lot from the way they used to
be right yeah try to get away with that
50 years ago good luck I would say
another thing that was appealing to me
about the sugaring was that I'm very
traditional absolutely I'm a 48 year old
man and I'm not very conservative I'm
very liberal but at the same time I like
taking care of someone who's taking care
of me my roommate I take care of my
roommate my best friend of 28 years
we've lived together 28 years and I've
taken care of him the whole time because
he once took care of me
um I take care of my friends I take care
of my dogs I have my friends over twice
a week or once a week sometimes and I
feed them I spend hundreds of dollars to
feed them and make sure there's drinks
there because I value my friends I like
taking care of others I like sharing
what I have I've given away millions of
of when I'm Millions but thousands of
dollars worth of gift cards and and and
Xboxes and PlayStations through a
YouTube channel and I didn't do it in
global giveaways to getting subscribers
I did it because it's Christmas time
this guy's been following me for a while
he mods for me on Discord or whatever
hey here's just free [__] yeah right on
do you ever feel like that's a gift in a
curse because I am like that and I have
been incredibly giving in my life and
there's times where I look at the people
I've given to and the lack of
appreciation and like or when I needed
something and they weren't there like do
you ever feel like
they say a fooling his money aparted
easily you know yeah and sometimes I
feel like a fool when I look back at the
things I've done for people dude the
first time I made money is when I
started my small internet business in 98
and I was doing web coding and stuff and
I was rocking like 30 it was like 45 000
a year now uh but that was going from
homelessness to that right and so I
spent money on everyone but myself I
didn't buy new clothes I didn't buy new
games I didn't do nothing I paid for
dinners for me and my fat ass friends
and we went to buffets and wrecked them
okay and I took everybody to the movies
because we like the movies and I paid
for everything and I pay for magic
troops I pay for hotel rooms okay and
then I went broke and my business
started failing and I'm like where the
hell are those people and there's two or
three there's definitely there my friend
Phil my friend Greg those guys are they
were definitely my friend chat
um but the rest of them fell away and
I'm like man I'm a [__] idiot if I
ever start making money again I will
never do it again and then I made money
and I did it again and I'll tell you why
I did it
um is because the joy of giving every
once in a while I say to myself that
person owes me something but they don't
owe me [__] okay you know what and that
definitely I've learned that as I've
gotten older like I'm like okay don't
let those [__]
stop you from being the good version of
you Bingo and I often say
um let's say you loan somebody 50 bucks
and you never get their money back and
they stop being your friend because of
it right okay here's the thing you want
you spent fifty dollars to find out they
were not the right person for you you
spent fifty dollars to get rid of a
piece of [__] what a bargain that person
gonna cost you thousands in the laundry
room right so true how much heartbreak
how much [__] misery I wish there was
more visible of a record of the the
amount of [__] I gave away when I was
making good money because there's all
these people I thought I could [__]
deserve to be broke and I'm like I'm
partially broke because I gave a [__]
look if I had a if I still had what I
gave away right now I paid my mortgage
off with it that's how much I gave away
so yeah but it is what it is you know
you're not going back to these girls I'm
just wondering what what uh physically
was there a pattern or will you try in a
bit of everything out I so
I'm gonna be real
[__] judgmental but I this is my
preference okay we're all about them if
we had our allowed them bro right
exactly yeah so I had always been
shipped with the big girls right my
ex-wife was not exactly skinny
um and so the one thing I was not
seeking out was women who have weight
issues and I don't mean thick if that's
fine hell I don't even mean Shelby I'll
date Shelby but if you were big and
you're if you're losing your battle with
your eating disorder we're probably not
compatible anymore other than the fact
given the fact that we're both addicts
to the same drug probably should not
co-mingle but because I've been shipped
with so many uh I'd say about half the
women that I've been long-term
relationships with had been plus-sized
women and I'd be very plus
um I was like let me go for the skinny
girl for a change let me see if I miss
skinnier more petite girl and there's
something funny about the looks that I
would get when I would be out with like
a 25 year old five foot tall girl who
like desperately needs a cheeseburger
and I'm feeding her that cheeseburger
that way right and people are like
what's that his daughter can't be his
daughter she's skinny or whatever I'm
like [__] the people's reactions that
was the best but I I was mostly
interested in and vibing with somebody I
was mostly interested in like hey do you
like Marvel shows let's watch Marvel
shows like you ever seen the you ever
seen the boys let's go watch the boys
like like I was looking for somebody
that had compatible interests
um at least you needed to be able to
fake it well enough uh and I think some
women certainly were uh but how many of
these how many of these girls do you
think you took out
it's embarrassing don't be embarrassed
across every man who's watching this
hasn't had an experience with your
family they paid for a woman in
somewhere in in 2017 my body count
was seven my long-term relationship
count was seven uh I'd never had a
casual hookup I'd never really and my
number First Dates I could count on two
hands right that just didn't go well
because uh by the time I have asked you
out we already know we're compatible I'm
never I don't risk I don't like
rejection right you're a mom right so
um I'm always going to be your friend
first and then when you let me know
you're ready then I'll end to it and I'm
always so surprised I get told I have
golden retriever energy a lot because
they're like I'm like dude it's so much
fun hanging out with you would you like
to do more than that I'm like you want
to do more than that and they're like
yeah we could have sex like holy [__]
sex I love sex you know
um I feel like so I was just happy you
were here right yeah so um men head
rejection the way like and I was talking
to some guys recently about this uh on
my live streams and the boys were saying
like how do I deal with rejection I'm
like get used to it bro this is part of
it no every month I don't okay how
handsome you are you're getting rejected
yeah accept it I I let it go one of the
smartest things I ever did
um a lot of people don't know this but
my first business I did adult web design
that led to me like shooting photographs
of beautiful women and selling that
content to uh pornographers right and so
that put me in a lot of strip clubs and
I learned how to be very chill around
strippers and naked women and just I get
building my confidence right
um and I was obviously there to uh do
business as well right so I was trying
to stay as professional as possible
right and that ultimately meant that I
became friends with a shitload of sex
workers
um and I learned very quickly do you
know what a sex worker wants to do more
than anything they want to dress down in
their shittiest ugliest pajamas they
want to take their makeup off they want
to put their hair up and they want to
lay in bed with a big fat soft guy who's
not going to try to [__] them and watch
a TV show that's what every sex worker
in the world who does that's what they
all want and occasionally one of the sex
workers this is me like man I'm really
glad we did that I'm going to [__] the
[__] out of you now and that was pretty
much my my experiences with that and
that became my experiences with sugaring
as well well cow is a very just hey I'm
just so glad you're here I'm just so
glad I'm talking to a pretty girl today
tell me about your life tell me your
stories tell me your problems how can I
solve them and that's I I genuinely take
an interest in every other person I ever
meet I want to know everything you have
to say I want to learn from your
experiences maybe you can learn from
mine too but I'm more interested in
listening than talking you said you're
on uh body count to seven after the
after tomorrow yeah I don't know what my
body count is anymore okay so it was a
you went out with a lot of these guys I
went I went Hog Wild yeah yeah yeah it
was amazing to the point that I I
realized I had a problem because I have
an addictive personality and I realized
I'd spent uh certainly six figures
across five years and I had some great
experiences and that included travel
expenses that introded Disneyland that
included all kinds of stuff I wanted to
pay I was paying to live the best life
I'd ever [__] lived to do ride and
ride visit Disneyland with beautiful
[__] girls let's go I love it yeah
it's everything I ever wanted to do a
little bit [__] everybody who's got a
problem with it I don't know I think the
biggest thing is a lot of people would
say
oh you were forcing women to have sex
with you just so they could pay their
rent like nobody had to [__] me I'm not
allowed to come and a lot of times most
of them nobody was right number one if
you think there's not a lot of sugar
daddies out there you're wrong there's
like a thousand in my small town they're
ready to go those women picked me check
this out right all of these Instagram
and I'm gonna use this model
who are in Dubai and there's never
anyone else in the photographs
oh you think the photographs of being
taken by her girlfriend
when she's in that swimming pool yeah
and it's a five-star hotel bro sugaring
is becoming it's the gift that keeps on
giving for these girls because without
it they'd all be working in [__]
phone shops and [__] supermarkets
right so if people are wondering where
the money's coming from when these girls
never post a brand deal this is the
unspoken truth of the internet right
thank you and you were just one of those
guys who was open to admitting it uh I
remember seeing a picture of you some
little goth chick
you by the way never a sexual partner oh
really we never dated we never said we
just hung out okay and I did spend some
money on her for sure yeah and she was
pretty ashamed of that at the time uh
but she was going through some [__] and
I helped her with her [__] yeah that's
one of my favorite things looking back
on all of that [__] if a girl made it in
my video if a girl made it in my my
YouTube channel
um or like my social media it probably
meant we never were a thing and I was
putting them out there to obfuscate with
who the people is actually hanging out
with but the people I'm actually hanging
out with you will never know anymore
because my ex-wife got put through hell
a dude took photos of her car parked in
front of her workplace once the centers
that to scare us dude like I I will
never tell another no you'll never know
who I'm actually [__] dating if I get
married I'll do it in another [__]
country so you can't [__] find it
okay you'll never know because why why
should a woman be heard just from having
the choice of being in my life so the
women that made it into YouTube videos
and stuff
um they all agree like Hey we're not
gonna have a romantic relationship let's
have a professional one let's do videos
together let's make videos and stuff
together was there a highlight
throughout that wild time where you were
like if they could see me now the
Disneyland trip was pretty great I never
showed the girl I showed videos but she
filmed like if somebody was buying that
camera you guys asked to ask your
question who was that behind that camera
yeah and they never did I was all
surprised by that but you know when
you're uh you're getting down to
business with these chicks I'm not like
what's the crap with your weight and
stuff like that okay all right let's get
really into it okay so chances are if
you and I were having sex we've known
each other for quite some time at this
we've been snapping all the time we've
been texting all the time we've had
several dates we've probably cuddled
them in bed a few times and now you've
decided for whatever reason you would
like to see boogie naked okay so I'm
going to prepare you for that by uh
explaining what you're in charge for I
want to tell you what a fupa is and
where my loose skin is and that the fact
that I have tits bigger than three women
combined and we're and how sex is going
to have to work and make sure that
you're fully informed and for when I've
never had a no after that I've never had
to know everybody's been okay with it
and then uh women all like men though
I've heard like women are really
understanding if anything they're
probably more worried about them you
know like in terms of their own bodies
half the time like to me like because
I'm not necessarily that proud of the
way I look with my shirt off and all
those so like I don't think I'm I don't
know if that's a manly thing but I don't
look at myself and think hey I'm this
you know what I mean I would murder my
dog to have your body when you talk I
may respected we all feel how we feel
but good Lord man no I dude I look like
somebody lit air out of a Macy's [__]
balloon okay it's a bad time what I mean
is is like for me as a man
we're not supposed to be the pretty
thing I feel like the the pressure is
more on the woman to be the exact same
thing I don't even think about you know
like I don't think of myself in that way
so like I'm
um I don't know I'm rambling here but
but in terms of the woman I I I'm not
surprised that they never gave any
issues I think what I've learned about
women especially because they're mostly
dated women in their 20s a couple in
their 30s
um and I I've often said it's because we
have more common interests because of
social media and gaming and and the
movies we watch stuff like that but if
I'm just being genuine and I like being
more genuine now that I post uh uh uh
psychedelics I just find women in their
20s to be more attractive I think a lot
of men do and I have no problem every
month every month does yeah by the way
ever like right and this is the thing
that you know it's the double standards
right it's when women have a choice of I
want a man to be over 6'4 I wanted to be
you know how big shoulders I want him to
earn over x amount of money it's a
preference yeah but when we won I want
big tits big awesome you know a
reasonably small weight a horrible
beauty standards that we're putting on
them and it's so unfair and it's like
there's no there's nothing wrong with
enjoying a beautiful woman I'll be
honest with you I when it comes to my
preferences short or tall black or white
uh I do think I prefer uh women with
some ethnic backgrounds I definitely
have an inclination for redheads but
none of that's going to keep me from
dating anybody right like I don't care
if you're a good person and you're fun
to talk to and fun to be around and you
have a loving caring nature uh we're
we're gonna be fine
um and I think that's I think that's the
thing I learned about women during my
sugaring face like obviously some of
them are they're just there for a
paycheck and I could tell pretty quick
and like we're not going to go very far
right because like you're a good reader
of people yeah I I'd like to think so
and I think you kind of have to be when
you grow up in an abusive home
um so you learn to pick up on it pretty
quick and hey if you're here for the
paycheck you're still going to get the
paycheck you can go home now but we're
not you're not you're not going to get
second paycheck okay and that's okay
um and then there's just some people we
don't Vibe with right and that's okay
you can move on it's like I mean that's
like dating right exactly it's what it
is it's it's it's dating but taking out
one of the more complicated steps in a
lot of ways right
um but then I think what I learned
during all of that time is that
regardless of what you look like if you
can treat a woman with the respect if
you're meeting the needs that they are
not getting met and a lot of these
younger men who are attractive do not
meet those needs and doesn't matter if
it's Financial emotional respect and I
brought all of that to the table I
respect your choice to Sugar I respect
your choice to live the life you're
having tell me your stories let me learn
from you how can I help you what do you
like to do what's fun for you let me
provide those things for you is your
rent paid is your child taken care of
and well fed oh cool if not I can help
with that let me help apparently that's
sexy
uh apparently even if you look like uh
his form of clayfaced you know but it's
it it's as old as time itself isn't it
that a man who was a provider women are
naturally going to gravitate towards
that and even when it's broke I mean I
did fine and I think it's because
I always try to be the person that
someone else needs but also be the
person that I always needed right like
this if I was that person this is the
person I would need so I'm gonna be that
person for them right you need a
listener oh I'm a good listener you need
somebody who can provide I'll provide if
you need somebody who doesn't treat you
like a sexual object I don't need to
treat you like that I want to treat you
like a person let's be people together I
know how you feel though because I went
to a strip club once yeah uh well I when
I went from a period where I was going
uh after my mother died I was going to
uh strip clubs uh just to take my mind
off of it and looking at big tits to
tell them to help with that
um
and I just talked to these girls and I'd
say that I'm a bit down my mom died I'm
getting [__] wasted but they were
nice you know and they they actually
like
um you'd have these little chats with
them and you'd be like there's a person
yeah this there's a person with a story
and I get how you could remove the uh
the situation that you were in and
forget all about that and just treat
them as a people the last time I was in
a strip club I wanted a bunch of friends
and uh they wanted to go I'm I'm over
them I I spent so much time on in the
20s right like yeah and the magic's gone
uh and but we got there and they just
didn't know what to do or how to do it
right so they're like setting in on our
little booth they're on our little couch
and like one of my friends like oh that
girl's really attractive and I'm like oh
you like her and I walked up to her like
hey my friend thinks you're attractive
he's got money and so she walked over to
sat in his lap and he's like oh my God
you're so good at this I'm like there's
like ordering a cheeseburger man that's
what we're here that's what they're for
that's what we are here for right and
then like I I found the house mom didn't
realize how started the house Mom
immediately uh but I figured out who the
house mom was after talking to her for a
few minutes and then like started
putting out like made sure she got
tipped very well because it's a very
good strip club guy I could find out of
the house mom is make sure she's taken
care of and then the girls will be all
over you for the rest of the night
because she's going to put in a good
word for you oh yeah he's a very
respectful guy he's got money
um and so for the rest of that night
they thought I was this [__] strip
club celebrity I haven't been in one 15
years you have to be careful in strip
clubs though they could take the pests a
little bit I noticed that they'd be
running a bill up on you without you
even real they will yeah yeah I'll be
very careful with the drinks nowhere and
stuff right and then definitely be
careful with the upsell and the
champagne room they will tell you that
there's No Sex in the Champagne Room
they are lying there is so much Sex in
the Champagne Room if you are not having
sex in the Shane perm room it's probably
because you look broke okay I had a
moment when I first got the old YouTube
money coming in and I had a had three
women dancing for me at the same time
but they they literally it was like but
I wanted a bit of different everything
so I had like a redheaded blonde and a
black girl something like that and they
all pushed their butts together and we
were all dancing at the same time and
I'm just sitting there like I'm a hammer
I'm like [__] hell this is cool
like you become 14 and you had like
immediately right and then this guy
walks in the strip club and he goes oh
[__] it's true
oh [__] I didn't really think there's
something I went through right and uh I
was like can you just not say anything
yeah when I was when I was helping out
that girl uh she had me coming to the
club every once in a while I met her
offline or on seeking
um it should turn out to be a spirit
person she's like yeah there's a guy
harassing me the club would you come to
the club I'm not sure I said I don't
watch it for a while she never let me
spend money on her at the club but she
encouraged me to spend money on
everybody else but I didn't recognized a
couple of times and not just like oh
that's Boogie from Fayetteville but
Boogie the YouTuber and one guy was
really slick about it he's like Lisa
when he goes you're broken
yeah man these girls are [__] hot I'm
like well couple of them yeah for sure
man and that's it but thank God it
didn't like blow up but I'm so open
about that kind of thing anyway yeah do
you want to hear I'm volunteering this
you want to hear my when I realized I
had a problem with this the sugaring oh
thank you
some in Dallas Texas
and I'm matching with girls and I match
with these two girls who claim to be
sisters
and they are beautiful and they
definitely look like sisters
dark hair that Ruby lips black eyes just
piercing black eyes look at these girls
and I am not interested with my
background especially I am not
interested in the incest [__] but
whatever it's a bucket list item I guess
and so I'll at least talk to the girls
right and they were very forward uh so
I'm like talking to them like are you
guys really sisters and like well why
don't we come to the bar at your hotel
we'll show you
and I'm like yeah I guess that's what
we're doing now I said we're going
downstairs and they're drinking without
having like Mountain Dew and [__]
chicken wings because I'm fat and uh and
like I'm like are you guys really
sisters like so it's kind of a bit that
we do we're actually half sisters so but
it's technically true I'm like [__]
they provide to their IDs Canadian ideas
they provided their IDs and they have
the same last name and they definitely
look like sisters and they're born like
eight months apart to then the story is
their dad cheated on their mom and
that's when they found each other later
in life and now they're doing this I'm
like and you know it's like
have sex with each other and she's like
well if we go to your room you could
watch and find out I'm like yeah man I
guess that's what we're doing
I guess I guess [__] so we're in the
room and sure enough they're like going
down on each other
and I'm not even like the turned on but
I've paid for this now so let's get
everything out of it you know and
so the oldest girl does all the talking
she's on top of me and she looks down at
me she goes I know who you are and I'm
like what are we gonna have a problem
because I've been blackmailed by the
very first girl I'm out seeking she
literally blackmailed me oh and so I'm
like are we gonna have a problem here
and she's like no no nothing like that
I'm a fan
and like can we not talk about this
while I'm inside you that would be great
and so we wrap up and everybody's
getting clean and taking a shower and uh
you know the the dirty part of the money
exchanging hands is now taking place or
whatever and I'm like what did you mean
you're a fan because that is a big role
for me I've never dated a fan because
they think they know you better than
they do if I've talked to a fan I'm
going to talk to you for months and
months and months before we even have
dinner because you need to know who the
real me is not your picture version of
me I gotta get to know me right so I'm
very careful about that that said
um she's like yeah yeah uh me and my
sister collect YouTubers
and I said You [__] what she goes
yeah yeah we've had sex with a lot of
YouTubers that's why we Mash with you oh
you're not normally our type and I'm
like Oh you mean because of the way I
look she goes financially I'm like oh
okay they're probably punching above you
right so they were
um Canadian escorts where I guess it's
legal with their part of Canada they're
in they're using seeking to pay their
way across their trip through the United
States to collect YouTubers did their
name job on the YouTubers yes so I said
what other YouTubers have you met and
she said I was in a Logan Paul video
[Laughter]
there's no way oh [__] she says
yeah I played Mario Kart with Logan Paul
her pink slips he won but he let us keep
her car Logan I'm sorry bro but you're
an eskimo brother that's what I said to
her I said wait a second did you [__]
Logan Paul and she said no of course not
the same way I didn't just [__]
boogie2988 and then she packed her [__]
and left no way Lauren Paul is an Eskimo
bro that's what I knew I hear Rock and
bottom that's what I knew
if I'm making the same life choices
that lead me to having sex with the same
Quebec prostitute is Logan [__] Paul
I I don't know if it's true Logan I
don't know if it's true but if it's
[__] true God help us man I'm so
sorry Logan's got some high numbers
let's be healthy I am sure I'm sure but
like dude a 48 year old man should not
be banging the same prostitute as Logan
Paul sisters though I didn't I didn't
want it I didn't know that was the worst
part about it it wasn't even the welcome
fan that wasn't doing well she was on
top of you good stuff
stuff you get the balls I got the deck
uh so then I I got home and that was
Circa end of 2019 and I'm like wow I
have a problem I have to quit so I
deleted that [__] and I got off the
website and then every once in a while I
like relapse and I'd be like I gotta
[__] I gotta meet somebody I gotta
talk to somebody and then like during
coven especially it was afraid to meet
anybody because you don't know where
people have been like I only get [__]
killed and then this is this breaks my
heart this is one of my least favorite
stories about the internet but met a
girl
um and I I tried to hide her on her at
the time but we did meet on seeking and
uh we like hit it off and actually hit
it off like a hundred percent to the
point that at one point she's like I
have no no man has ever met my son
I would like you to meet my son and no
man has since I've been divorced five
fifty five years ago
great and me and her son hit it off uh
it turns out I didn't know I was
autistic at the time but he's autistic
and we liked the same [__] we had the
same [__] and like we're like chill and
[__] and just like [__] watch siren
head videos on YouTube and just have the
best time doing it and um and so I was
taking care of her and hers I paid for
her son's education how old is this one
uh he was eight at the time I guess he'd
be about 10 now and
um he was having they hadn't he they
were paying like the worst [__]
online school that they could afford
um but he was not performing uh because
of autism and the he was pretty severely
autistic and so I was like well how much
would it cost to do like a specialized
School online course it's like three
grand per semester I'm like well I
obviously have that please let me do
that right like let's get him a good
education I like the kid he's a good guy
um and so I ended up doing that for her
and then I love that by the way well
done well thank you man uh you know I
soon I always have to say I obviously
got my end out of it as well I had a
beautiful woman who was blowing me up
every day so I was so happy to to be
taken care of too
um but that said
the internet founder uh I took a photo
of her hand and she was holding a a rose
gold iPhone and she had a tattoo on her
finger and by that they found her
profile on seeking even though she
hadn't logged into a free ear and even
though she was not in the same [__]
town they had to go two counties over to
find her because that's where she was
listed as being
and they started harassing the shadow
they emailed her and they're like they
were somebody sent her a message on
Instagram
uh we're going to call Child Services
because you are bringing that child
around a known pedophile which is
obviously not a thing
but this has happened a lot of times
Child Services get called for no good
reason on YouTubers all the time it's
like uh being uh when they said the SWAT
team around I suppose uh so uh that was
like right before Christmas of that year
and I immediately made the decision to
break it off with her because I didn't
want to put the family through that and
I was worried about our family situation
as well like I didn't know the child
services was going to find anything but
I didn't think they would but like you
never know one of her child got
separated from her for some [__]
[__] reason I we certainly didn't
have good experience with travel
Services when I was coming up right
um and so I got her through Christmas I
made sure her and her son had an awesome
[__] Christmas and then New Year's
Eve we've broken off and that that one
[__] me up that was so bad I do you
think there was other reasons behind
breaking it off though
I
it was it was a lot of responsibility
yeah um and also we had did some
distance between his two so we didn't
get hang out like every day and that's
more of my preference and I think we
were also getting to the point that
maybe we were going to move in together
and I didn't know if I was ready for
that since I'd not lived with any woman
since my divorce and honestly hadn't
really planned to I didn't think I was
ever gonna live with a woman ever again
um so there's probably other people the
big thing isn't it when you've gone from
marriage divorce to then okay we're
starting again it you know it's only
natural to get cold feet yeah I've been
talking to somebody for about
six seven months now I I think I think
it's probably going to be my last Rodeo
I think this I hope this is the one uh I
hope she's listening too by the way I
probably send this but that's uh
um the internet will never know anything
about her ever ever ever I would even
put a [__] bill in her name she moves
in you'll never [__] know she lives
so she won't even get mail there you'll
never [__] know she exists isn't it I
hate that that's that way but that's how
it's been for every person I've ever
loved
um she says we can Vlog together she's
like I'd love to be in your videos and
stuff like that I'm like you don't know
what you're asking but maybe we'll maybe
she'll prove it wrong maybe we'll do it
why is it like you have this this
issue with these people because
they don't I remember you doing like
these videos about there's this group on
Reddit who hate me and I was I mean I
have no idea about like I pretty much
Shield myself from my my own hate I was
let alone uh other people say I was like
I don't get involved I'm just like I'm
making YouTube videos I don't give a
[__] about like if you want to hate them
here then whatever I'm just gonna be me
right but yeah but you really seem to
talk a lot about this group of people
who have a problem with you what do you
think this what stems that so there's a
lot of different reasons number one I do
think I've attracted uh a special group
of crazy people
um I'm not exactly sure why maybe they
hate fat people maybe they hate the
choices I've made maybe they hate that
I've been successful maybe they hate
that I'm I had a victim complex whatever
it is
um but they're obsessed too a bizarre
level that is this one guy on Twitter
who I've blocked at least a thousand
times over the last eight years and he
always has a very similar name and
always says and rustoff in a similar way
so I always know it's him like I'll
block you again today and then he makes
through I've gone through five accounts
in one day with that guy and it's
fascinating that that guy has that life
that's you know after all I've got a
little theory on this I don't know if
you'll agree but I remember when I was
on the come up uh the place I was from
um at the I moved to London from a place
called Newcastle north of the north of
England just before you get to Scotland
and there was like a you know a handful
of particularly nasty you know like
where they're really nasty towards oh
yeah I particularly go out of their way
and and I I remember thinking like is it
because you look at me and think why
isn't that me like you're from where I'm
from like they identify with you and
like kind of what you were saying
earlier about how they kind of see
themselves in you and if I I feel like
that maybe there's a little bit of like
that should be me he doesn't deserve
that like he has nothing oh I've heard
people say exactly those yeah and and
when they have this like energy it
towards you of like you've got this life
I've got this life that unfair I'm from
the same place as you I could see what
you see I could be who you are like do
you know and I I always thought like
it's the opposite for me because when I
see people from my hometown grow and do
well yeah I love that exactly I'm on
there like I'm telling everyone like who
listened to a friend of mine who is a
singer from Newcastle or all of that and
when I watched you grow and become this
person I loved I was like oh this is the
unlikely hero this is amazing but for
other people I realized that they don't
get inspired by that it does the
opposite it shines a light on what
they're not doing right it's like he's
doing all of this he's achieved all of
this despite his way issues and his
upbringing and everything else he's
still found a way to win what's my
excuse and maybe that's the the actual
problem there for them because they
can't and so when I say I do think
that's a good chunk of that there's
other people out there and we can talk
about that as well but the people that
feel that way
um I always say to them then just do it
let's do it if I can do it on my bedroom
you can do it out of your bedroom tick
tock's a thing get on Tick Tock right
now start making Tick Tock videos right
now like why are you maybe you're not
good at social media but maybe you're
good at something else be good at that
thing do the thing that you're good at
spend less time learning about what
other people are [__] doing and worry
about what you're doing right it's
unhealthy to be obsessed with some fat
[__] you've never met from Arkansas how
why why this why do you think about me
at all I don't like Jake and Logan Paul
very much I made that pretty abundantly
clear over the years okay do you know
how much time I spend other than making
this example with them the how much time
I spent thinking about Jake and Logan
Paul zero I don't tweet about alone
think about them and watch the videos
and I'll look at them I don't want to
hear about them I don't care about them
[__] them they're not even on the radar
okay because they're just not people I
enjoy the company of I'll shake their
hand if I made them I'll say hi I'll be
perfectly complite but that's about it
that's the the limit of it there's other
YouTubers out there that I just [__]
openly hate the content they're making I
think they're putting bad [__] of the
world I'm not gonna spend my time
thinking about it I want to think about
me I'm gonna think about my life I'm
gonna think about my family I don't
think about my friends do that most
cancellations they're not really angry
at what you've done or said they're
using it as an excuse absolutely as a
stick to beat you with absolutely
because they don't like you oh this is
why as somebody who's been canceled like
eight times right let's use Louis CK as
an interesting example okay because at
the end of the day what Louis CK did was
wrong so for those who don't know this
comedian by the name of Louis CK who has
a very unique Kink of liking to
masturbate in front of willing
participants and so he would use his
position of privilege like writing on
the Chris Rock show for example and then
asking dancers on that show hey would
you like to go back to my room to jerk
off knowing that he's their boss and
then they would be like I guess I kind
of have to so I will I don't know and
that's wrong to do right and Louis will
agree that that's wrong to do right
probably should have asked people that
worked under me to jerk off in front of
them right I have no problem you want to
jerk off for somebody that's here okay
go nuts I don't have a problem with that
are we in here to King Shame but that's
what gets you off just be careful about
who you ask all right
um because sometimes people feel
pressured into doing [__] and you
shouldn't pressure people on doing [__]
they don't want to do that said he went
back to making comedy and is selling the
[__] out of his specials and he can't
get anybody to sell them for him he's
got no Publishers he's not on your
Netflix sells them right through his own
website and he teaches the very
interesting lesson of they can't cancel
you unless you let them that's it he
keeps providing value he keeps creating
comedy people who find that valuable
continue to purchase it and his life
continues right and I like you know like
his jokes about it have been kind of
funny uh you know Dave Chappelle is
another comedian that God knows they
tried to cancel him because of wrong
thinking I'll be honest with you I
openly disagree with Dave Chappelle I
don't like the way he thinks I do not
think the way he thinks still think it's
funny and interesting to listen to him
say it so I continue to watch his
specials I probably always will because
because the reality is sometimes we say
things we don't really mean to make
people laugh because it sounds funny oh
yeah that was me as a nutshell for the
majority of my life I'm saying good Lord
and I've been canceled multiple times
for this and and it's it's one of those
things where they they go oh he really
meant that though right it's like Noah
if I could get away with it right right
now if I could get away with it right
now but I would say the most [__] up
[__] in the world because I don't mean
it and that's the comedy the joke is
that clearly I don't mean it of course
and what I've noticed is you're one of
the few people who's been around YouTube
to see the change when you came into
YouTube it was Broadcast Yourself say
what the [__] you want yeah we're gonna
pay you it's great yep now do two hour
long video essays on the most banal [__]
yeah that's what it is now it's a
completely different place where it's
changed completely and what are you as a
Creator feeling like now in the creative
process in the direction you're good
because of these boundaries that
restrict someone who has dark humor like
you do for the people who don't know
um my entire Francis character was
largely demonetized from the very
beginning even before there was a yellow
icon I would get the lowest paying ads
only and I made a fraction of the money
I I should have made because I continued
to make Francis sketches Francis videos
[__] [__] [__] piss this whenever
smashing stuff breaking stuff and as
soon as I got a YouTuber at my YouTube
rep's like you gotta stop the swearing
and you gotta stop being angry and like
that's the entire character so go [__]
yourself that's what I'm choosing to do
but you're not going to get paid if you
do it well my audience will take care of
me and they have for the most part I'm
very grateful for that taking care of me
still to this day they're buying
t-shirts for this fight God bless you
um and I eventually even even I was like
a few years ago I'm like God I guess I
have to peel it back I I look into the
financials I'm looking at the the fact
that they're bearing my videos in the
algorithm I'm looking the fact that I'm
getting canceled over and over again
I've gotta I've gotta change things and
it's very frustrating because
I don't like hate speech I don't want
anybody saying the inward this on on my
platform I don't I understand but where
they're choosing to draw the line is so
ludicrous I can't pretend to be angry I
can't pretend to have a fight it's uh
it's I like on one [__] planet I I
don't know it's a parody though the
character is a parody and you had all
the courage he's a parody of me that's
the thing about it like 16 year old me
not in control of his autism
non-controllables from experts disorder
I would play a video game I'd smash a
controller I remember very succinctly
one time in high school I picked up a
desk and threw it through a window
because they were going to tell my mom I
was in trouble and I knew I was gonna
get the [__] beat out of me at home so
that's 16 year old me that's who Francis
was based off of how the [__] am I not
allowed to make fun of me unfortunately
because of tick tock
I believe in Tick Tock anyway I mean I
could be wrong but like [__] dumb quick
flick uh bubble gum content is becoming
the way like you know you probably
remember people like Bill Hicks I would
imagine of course yeah yeah and like
Geniuses who were
I don't know if they're coming in this
generation like you know that generation
of where Chris Rock Eddie Murphy and all
of these Legends would fall and when I'm
watching YouTube content I'm not saying
Talent like that no we're in such
to begin with I'll tell you my YouTube
algorithm is currently or is it my Tick
Tock algorithm I'm so proud of it when I
first signed up for tick tock it was
half naked girls dancing and I'm like
[__] PornHub exists why do I need this
right
um and now I have it finally tuned
towards mental health [__] uh it is the
occasionally girl but not in those so
early like the dirtier ones it's more
like the ones talking about mental
health and [__] it's stand-up comedians
and dogs that's my entire ticks like I
was bringing up right now I'd show it
that's all it's going to be Tick Tock
algorithms basically right but that's
the point I'm making is that we are now
a slave to algorithm yeah and uh it
might not be true for everybody if
you're watching this you might not think
curiously to the album then maybe you
are not in the midority of stupid people
are certainly always just going to do
what the algorithms I was going to do
and watch what the algorithm tells in
the watch YouTube subscriptions
it's all about algorithm and I've I've
learned that and it's like you need to
tell me I've worked this hard all this
time as you have four million
subscribers and literally I can upload a
video and get 10 and that's that's the
point though is is it they've completely
abandoned the idea of subscription which
I personally used to love yeah and now
because because of I mean Tick Tock
specifically I I've only just started
Tick Tock like a couple of months ago
and I didn't really use it much but I
just tried out the other day and I was
like okay let me so I watched like 30
seconds about this thing of fentanyl uh
this epidemic in America yeah yeah and
then I flicked and I was like okay I
flicked a few more times and there was
another fentanyl yeah you know I was
like whoa like it it's scary I was like
I can't believe how much this is reading
what I'm watching here like because
because I came at it from a blunt Slayer
I'd never watched anything before it was
switching on immediately to every little
thing and anything I swiped off of
quicker boom disregarded that never
served another one of those videos of
the fence and I'll keep coming it's like
I'm [__] loving fentanyl all right
yeah it's interesting because
to begin with tick tocks regulations
owned by [__] China and they are not
as
restrictive as YouTube seems to be these
days like it's fascinating you cannot
upload [__] to you like Tick Tock seems
Progressive compared to YouTube these
days that said
um YouTube now has the shorts feed and
every time I log into the short speed
it's like you really want to watch
Stephen Crowder Clips don't you and I'm
like not really man I don't necessarily
agree with that guy yeah and it's like
what about Joe Rogan you want to watch
it a lot of Joe Rogan I'm like I watch a
little bit of Joe Rogan like anybody but
that's not the only thing I want to
watch but what about this neckbeard
screaming about how much he hates women
uh no I definitely don't want to watch
that that's it's so convinced that
that's what I want to watch
um and I like I keep trying to train it
I'm like no dude I don't like this I do
not like this oh I do like this I do
like this it's like all right but here's
another Stephen Crowder clip and I'm
like but I'm not a fan yeah why are you
doing this I find Instagram and YouTube
to be both pretty poor by comparison
like tick tock's algorithm seems to be
on another planet it's scary actually
yeah yeah well Boogie I want to thank
you for coming thank you perhaps unless
it's been a good time this has been uh
you've delivered like everything I
wanted yeah I'm glad any other questions
whenever you got for me I'm here I'd
like to just text you like a man and
just keep in touch with you yeah of
course absolutely
um but my final question I'll ask
everyone this and uh I think uh it's a
nice way to end is how would you like to
be remembered
when it's all said and done
boogie2988 well I think there's two
answers to that well take your time
there's no pressure I think the old
answer would be something like uh I'd be
cool to like have a little burial site
in my town oh that YouTuber was from
here and other people in St Paul
Virginia all that YouTuber well you know
he made good he got out of this small
town you know lived a good life
uh I don't know I don't think I care
about that kind of thing anymore I think
what I care about is there's people out
there who've
found my videos when they
were suicidal and and they saw me talk
about my suicidal feelings and thoughts
or people who've
uh I grew up in abusive homes that are
struggling with that and they saw my
videos talking about it or maybe just
some more really obese guy who looked at
me because of another more really obese
guy there's a way we have a kidney ship
you know two fatties you know that guy's
fat I'm interested I want to learn about
it right we maybe they looked at me
because of that and felt a little bit
better about their own bodies their own
minds or maybe they felt Superior to me
they're like I'm not as [__] up as him
I'm not as ugly as him or whatever it is
but I just like to remember I I'd like
to be remembered by those people as just
someone that helped them along the way
that's it that's it yeah I have to build
a shrine I'll have to write a book don't
have to none of that [__] because
all that shit's temporary anyway but if
they can carry that with them for the
rest of their lives and and hopefully
Into The Ether
um and and and my model the universe
that I got from psychedelics is true
when we meet each other in The Ether
again we can hug each other and and and
say like hey man you helped me and
they'll be like
[__] yeah I'm glad you did he helped me
by watching the videos and by being
there and by supporting me and helping
me along my way and and then we can roll
up new characters and say see you in the
next one
you help me
I think the biggest thing I'll always
remember remind everyone of every time I
ever hear that okay people I met a fan
um I think she's gonna be a friend we've
been talking for a while now uh but at
this last convention I went to and she's
like oh I was diagnosed with cancer a
few years ago and I watched your videos
and your friend Michael's videos and and
they really helped me during that period
of time and I'm [__] are you kidding
me you're the hero you're the one
kicking cancers ass you're the one who
survived for the last three years here
the world is going to survive the next
15 years I ain't got nothing to do with
that if you were the one who built this
business you're the one who did the
podcast you're the one who did the show
I'm glad that I could be a minor
distraction along the way maybe an arrow
that points a Direction but that's all
I'll ever be in somebody else's life but
I'm glad to be that
that was boogie2988 on the true Geordie
podcast YouTube's Underdog hero oh thank
you man you you are you make me feel
very good about myself and I'm really
glad we got a chance to do this man
awesome awesome I hope everyone enjoyed
it if you have come on sure buggy some
love you gotta check this channel out
the link for it will be in the
description below he's back better than
ever and he's fighting yeah at Wembley
tomorrow oh God I temporarily forgot
that I was so busy in this podcast
should I have to fight a guy in like 24
hours give him Allison but it puts on
West Virginia on his ass you should damn
well better be absolutely yeah [__] yeah
yeah let's go and kill him
laughs
[Music]